welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host definition
aka your friendly neighborhood spoiler
man and as we're dealing with the
multiverse i thought i'd reach out to my
other self to get some help breaking
down spider-man 3.
the 2021 marvel movie starring tom
holland has been living rent-free in my
head for the past three months
and i swear that's that's that's not a
rent pun it's had a whole host of new
cast members and characters added to its
roster
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down everything we know so
far about the movie
it's the pizza time of your life and
we'll be discussing andrew garfield's
casting
the return of kirsten dunst and a lot
more if you enjoy the video then please
punch that thumbs up button and make
sure you click subscribe as we'll be
doing a lot of updates on the film
before it's released in december 2021
and that brings us to our first bit of
info that you need to know
spider-man 3 is due to debut on december
17th next year
and rumors are that it's so good it'll
have you dancing in the street
and making make making a bit of a fool
of yourself now
though delays have been rife over the
past year i have to believe that there's
some good in the world
and that by the time we get to it
theaters will be open and operating
regularly unless warner brothers has
destroyed the entire industry by then
either way i can't see this movie
missing its deadline and this time next
year we'll probably be crying tears of
joy reading the early reviews for it
or tears of sadness because it's sony
anyway
the film is currently being shot and
though we have very little info
in regards to exactly what happens in
the plot i think it's fair to say that
the movie will open the door to the
multiverse and be bringing back
a whole host of characters including
past peter parkers
now this is probably going to be because
of doctor strange who we know is going
to feature in the film
according to reports and leaks in one
division scarlet witch will open a
doorway to a pocket dimension
so that she can live out her perfect
life with vision things go awry
and this will spin off into doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
which will obviously open the door to
more characters coming across
wonder is apparently the madness in the
multiverse of madness
and she may accidentally open portals
across the multiverse
to pull different villains across
electro yeah
are you sure you want to bring him
across okay
now our first bit of casting news did
come out all the way back
45 years ago in october 2020 with the
announcement that jamie foxx would be
reprising his role as spider-man's most
exciting electrical enemy
at the end of the amazing spider-man 2
an energy blast was fired at him which
apparently caused him to explode though
it is possible that he's simply
transported to another reality
in a now deleted instagram post fox
shared an image that showed a poster for
the third film
and in it were toby mcguire andrew
garfield and tom holland
the caption also read won't be blue in
this one but a thousand percent badass
so it could be that the electro we get
is more in line with the comics
and likely from another universe
altogether this is also probably
how alfred molina is returning to in
spider-man 2 the character of course
died which
spoiler alert made it seem unlikely that
he could ever return
however as of yesterday doc ock is
officially back
and he'll be causing a lot of trouble
for the web head so whilst a dead guy
is normally pretty armless hey the fact
that he's back
probably means that he'll have been
picked from a slightly alternate
universe to the sam raimi one
this was of course shown with j jonah
jameson at the end of far from home who
though played by the same actor as the
original trilogy
did seem to be a slightly different
person to what we've seen before
there are rumors that jk simmons is also
returning
and when morbius was announced it was
said that the actor had signed on for
three films
including far from home the jared leto
led one
and an unknown property which is likely
going to be spider-man 3.
in a 2020 interview with siriusxm
simmons said the following
there is a future for jay jonah jameson
after a several year hiatus
there is one more jjj appearance in the
can and from what i'm hearing
there's plans for yet another so
hopefully jjj will continue
now and forever sorry that was terrible
that
now what this does open the door to and
no i won't pay the rent until you fix it
is other returning villains from the
franchise i would absolutely
love to see willem dafoe back sandman
and even venom not you topher get get
the hell out of here
because of all this info it does seem
like the studio are going to use this
movie to launch the sinister six to kill
spidey once and for all
you may remember that at the end of the
amazing spider-man 2
the group were teased but as this
franchise was mothballed
or other spider-ball day those plans
seem to have stumbled
however we have enough villains now to
do a full sinister six movie
and who knows who could be in the lineup
actually think that mysterio
will be back and the master of illusions
could definitely be a formidable
opponent in the lineup
michael mando also teased that he's
going to be the scorpion
there's doc ock electro and of course
vulture who appeared in the mobius
trailer
and that leaves room for one more now i
would love to see the most dastardly
character of all return
and that is of course the pizza guy from
spider-man 2.
either way there's gonna be a lot of
characters after the old web slinger
and he's probably gonna need some help
to to beat those guys down
now we do know that andrew garfield will
be returning in the movie
and this has been confirmed by several
different outlets
originally i saw andy signal discussing
it before there was accidentally a
trailer posted on friday by the latin
american sony channel
which showed all three peter parkers
side by side in a montage
that video was taken down faster than
you can say fire that intern
and though it's offline we do know what
was said in it
the trailer had the text who is your
favorite spider-man
huh you don't have to choose in the
marvel multiverse
anything can happen in spider-man 3 you
will quite possibly see everyone
yes the three peter parkers saving the
world together
so that pretty much confirmed it and
those sony are still remaining
tight-lipped at this point we can see
that that everyone is pretty much back
oh so that's why they call it spider-man
3
uh tom holland the original spoiler man
himself
also kind of let slip last year that
this was the direction that things were
going
i say kinda as he didn't confirm or deny
anything but yeah the lad has a terrible
poker face
let's watch the clip with spider-verse
which we got a couple of months ago and
then this film sort of touches on this
idea of sort of the multiverse and kind
of different people in different
universes coming in
uh any chance there's a multiverse in
which andrew garfield spider-man and
tony maguire spider-man and
spider-man all meet together clashing
no we don't because and then you sort of
just say that everyone just comes from a
different universe
but would you want that though would you
want that's maybe that's a better
question yeah
would we want that i mean as a fan i
would
is your is your no answer and answer in
and of itself
the thing about this film that's so
exciting right is we take spider-man to
europe and what's so cool about that is
we've never seen spider-man in europe
okay so no confirmation there but look
here the lad the lag can't keep a secret
out loud
and it looks like this is all happening
now as mentioned earlier we did get a
report just yesterday from collider that
said andrew garfield and kirsten dunst
had signed on
so we will be looking into both their
universes toby mcguire is apparently
still in negotiations and emma stone is
reportedly also being asked to come on
board
pregnancy permitting this story has now
picked up amongst other outlets
so he can pretty much tick it off as
confirmed i think the main reason that
things like the sony trailer got deleted
and no official word has been announced
from the studio it's because
things are still going on in regards to
maguire and sony obviously wanna
announce the three all in one go to have
a big bombastic moment that completely
breaks the internet
dc are gonna be so annoyed that they
delayed the flash because
the multiverse was their original plan
but marvel just swung in
saw what they could do and went yoink
anyway there's a whole host of
characters and we also have rumors that
miles morales may be appearing in the
movie
alongside his uncle aaron played by
donald glover
this was of course teased and spider-man
homecoming and
apparently the end of the film will set
up a miles franchise that will see him
divert off into his own stuff
and allow for holland to have his own
continuity whilst miles also gets one
too
sony are clearly pushing the character
and after the success of both into the
spider-verse and the miles morales game
does make a lot of sense so lots and
lots of things going on
and i've even heard that tom holland
might be in this movie at some point
hey you're having that now after
spider-man 3 the actor will have been in
six marvel movies
so it does make sense for them to start
looking at different options
and when they're making a madame web
movie you know they probably have a lot
of plans
obviously i'm really interested to see
where things could go
i just hope that everyone gets a
substantial role infinity war and
endgame
showed us that you could have a lot of
characters in a film and if an audience
were familiar with them
then they could be done justice i hope
that's the case here
and who knows we might even get a
three-hour epic that not only ties into
the title
but also allows the characters room to
breathe actually thinking the movie
might end with peter holding a press
conference and then one of the other
spider-men will come in to clear his
name
it's it's one of the worst plot devices
ever yeah but
they have the opportunity to do it and
it also ties back to
those those 60 spider-man moments anyway
that's
a lot for now yes muck and no i won't be
paying for these pizzas
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and also
who you want to see in it if you enjoy
this video then please subscribe to the
channel
and also drop a thumbs up so you never
miss a video or update
if you want something else to watch then
definitely check out our initial
reaction to the news
which is going to be linked at the end
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the lord of the rings 4k box
set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of december so make
sure you get involved
you want to support the channel and get
to see content early and please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come chat us on the discord
server linked in the description or
heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it till the end of the
video you've been the best i've been
paul
sorry i've been deaf edition i'll see
you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you